Another common need in building such situation
awareness applications is that a computation may need
to get correspondingly timestamped items from several
different sensor sources. So, for instance, in this
picture I'm showing you a video source,
an audio source, a text source, and gesture
source. And this computation, in order to do
its high level inferencing, it wants to use
the multiple modalities of sensing that's available
to generate high level inference that can
be more robust. And this is where bundling of streams that PTS allows comes in
handy. PTS allows streams to be grouped
together, as a stream group. And any number
of such streams can be grouped together and labelled as a group. And in creating
a stream bundle like this, a computation
can specify that, for this stream group, this
guy is the anchor stream. For instance, we could name the video as the anchor
stream for this particular stream group. All
the other streams within the same stream group
are dependent streams on the anchor stream. And
in PTS there's a primitive for getting a
group get, say, get corresponding timestamped items from all of the streams
in a particular stream group. The group get primitive is once again a way
of reducing the pain point for a domain expert. And having to go out and fetch
individual items from each one of these streams, and selecting temporally
correlated items from all the other dependent streams. That burden is
taken away by PTS by providing this group get, where you can get
correspondingly timestamped items from all the streams in a given group.